bungie just showed off the vest Ian
outpost it's their new social space in
the reef and made a lot of announcements
today now Eric you actually have not
been playing destiny recently you kind
of fell out of fell out of touch with it
or fell out of love with it so is there
anything in the house of wolves DLC that
they show to you that you're interested
in definitely there's a lot to be
excited for I kind of came into watching
the stream thinking you know they're
probably not some cool stuff the
upgrading weapons thing you know is a
cool thing that we all wanted we didn't
know exactly how it would work but they
broke it down for us i think the weapon
upgrade thing is pretty paramount in
this it's way faster less grindy the
three new MPC is that they showed look
interesting I guess we haven't seen the
endgame content yet which is kind of the
big deal but in terms of like quality of
life and just these minor changes of the
weapon upgrades and the armor upgrades
and just trying to diversify people's
like looks and styles and stuff like
that that's cool to me the first thing
that we should talk about is probably
the weapon upgrades now on actually the
armor upgrades to your using this stuff
called ethereal light to bring it all
with you you'll earn the ethereal light
through but what trials of Osiris and
balls the prison of elders there's
multiple chances iron banner it's just
kind of like that orangey I'm kind of a
little nervous because I'm not sure you
know how frequent that's going to drop
but at least there's multiple scenarios
for you to go in and like okay I'm gonna
do this event or activity and then
hopefully I'll get it you know like that
one guy that gets in the nightfall week
one's gonna be like hey guys i got my
ethereal light nightfall and i am what's
so important about that too is a lot of
people had their vex mythic glass from
the vault of glass and other weapons
where they work so hard to get it and
then just instantly invalidated once
crotas end' dropped so now like you can
actually go back and take all those
weapons that you love while all the
legendary weapons that you loved and
also separately the exotics can be
upgraded without losing progress and now
all that's going to come with you
through the game which i think is really
smart decision on bungees part yeah I
think it's gonna I think if anyone stop
playing like me like this is one of
those changes that when you came into
crotas end' you're like I really wish I
could use my fav bring her but I kind of
get why they didn't give you that option
because they had new
weapons so usually in other MMO games
even though this isn't an MMO game they
kind of go ok you get you earn this raid
to your weapon and it's like this is
good for this raid but now there's a new
raid so there's a new raid to your
weapon then they kind of separate them
and so that's kind of what they did in
code is n but now since there isn't a
raid and there's new activities they're
kind of like okay you guys work really
hard to get these weapons let's let you
upgrade them or vice versa if you didn't
get that weapon before in Baltic lass
now it's actually worth going back into
vault of glass to go get that paper that
you didn't get the first time now we
don't know if that paper is going to be
like the new version if you do vault now
or if it's the old version I would guess
is probably the old version that you
upgrade but either way it's still good
because you're going to get an awesome
weapon or weapon that you used to love
using and you can use it now and it's
viable another thing you can now do with
your new guns are the new weapons in
this dlc is reforging which i think the
community has been asking for it's
something they've done a little bit in
iron banner they played with the idea
but that weapon Smith let's be honest
was mostly useless after level 20 so
like now you can go to the gunsmith you
can take the new weapons and you can
reroll in reroll until you get those
explosive rounds you always wanted or
whatever your favorite perk is yeah i
mean i've been i've been asking for like
personally with in the office i've been
asking for reforging for a while like
you said they did test the waters in
iron banner and that's where i had a lot
of fun i farmed my tamura / and I rolled
it till I got you know field scout and
and the perks I wanted and same with you
know fell winters lie if you wanted the
shotgun you rolled it the way you wanted
to and now with the new weapons new
legendaries at least in the game you're
able to do that and that's a big change
and finally the gunsmith gets to do
something so you some telemetry 'he's
reportages so you actually go to him you
know where's before you're like yeah
thank ya you know let's be honest if the
gunsmith were any good he'd be working
for a thorough sore somebody like that
yeah oh just like the only guy they
could hire to get into the tower on that
salary continuing to make your leveling
progress easier now the speaker has a
full material exchange to which is new
and that's that's really cool like not
having to grind errors back up to
whatever level you need to you know do
radiant shards for radiant energy it's
just kind of your one-stop shop now yeah
I mean like for all the people that I've
been sitting on ascendant shards it's
any material you finally have a way to
you know trade and get
21 it's not even like previously like
you said eris morn you had to be level
four and then you can pay like 750
glimmer now it's just if you have it
it's like 50 glimmer here you go you
want a radiant material great you want
an ascended material great you can even
buy glimmer which is kind of interesting
they haven't I don't think they're going
to increase the glimmer cap which is I
think is ok but but yeah now the speaker
is kind of more relevant other than some
emblems and capes and stuff that you
could get before I go back to the reef
let's just touch really quickly on there
was like three NPCs who seemed a little
bit interesting first one was Petra
she's your main quest giver she lost her
eye and a knife juggling accident I'm
pretty sure that's true probably one of
the interesting things that deach talked
about was how they've claimed that
they've learned from there I'm gonna go
ahead and say poor storytelling choices
in the past we'll see if she can
actually give you missions with new
stories which I'm very interested in
being a fan of the grimoire but at the
same time they also said the grimoire
was not getting any significant upgrade
or inclusion in the game so although
there was one ghost in the new social
space I think there's two actually I
came to life and found both of them will
have to see Petra is pretty much like an
eris morn though from like what we can
tell she's serving the same purpose
she's gonna be your main quest giver
she's going to kind of guide you through
the story tell you about different
events you do finally get to see her
like you said with one eye instead of
with a mass she did come before into the
tower to sell you some of the Queen's
wrath stuff away a long time ago she has
an awesome ship I would say the first
ship that looks different compared to
every other boxee ship yeah every other
ship just kind of looks like an a-wing
as you put it or some ballsy version of
an a-wing and like this one's actually
finally going to be unique looking yes I
mean we'll see if she has anything else
other than just her like quests and some
shaders and stuff like that but again
she is Paul your main story person so
hopefully it's a slight upgrade from
Aris the other two interesting
characters one was verax who was the
basically the prison of elders warden
he's also he's a fallen so it's kind of
interesting I guess not all of the
Fallen abandoned the queen she had some
loyal subjects left over you're giving
them a little bit more personality than
just like oh I got four arms and I shoot
you he's got four arms but to
Mr robotic and it's true he's
interesting because he's going to have
you know set of like gear that you can
buy from him armored weapon and there
was this third kind of gambling type
item or something this this third kind
of mysterious item but that's going to
change week to week so you're going to
need to like you know earn your prison
of elders rep and you know I think
weapon cores and armor cores that I
think will drop from the prison of
elders and then you will exchange that
with very explore you know either the
gloves or chest or something that you
want that week or weapon and he has I
think some ships and some other stuff as
well and then finally the last
characters brother Vance who's in charge
of the trials of Osiris now travel Cyrus
and how that's going to interact with
prison of elders and you're sort of
weekly play thurs we're not entirely
sure about that yet like they said I was
going to change every week I think that
I'm not sure what's going to change but
I wouldn't be surprised if there is some
variety in it is i think a weekend event
though i think it's like a friday to
tuesday when the resets he it's uh it's
more of like that pvp i think it's like
a 3v3 maybe arena-style type thing but
again you'll earn rewards in there they
quickly kind of glossed over and like
browse through some of his items but he
looks like he has you know blue packages
and purple packages it may be some type
of gambling type mechanic were it's like
gamble for your osiris gear and hope
that you get lucky maybe i don't know
and then he has i think he has three
consumables which they kind of browse
through really quickly I think dan said
like one of them was like a mercy one
where if you play you still get like to
kind of like tokens or rewards even
though you might have lost or something
like that so interesting to see how that
plays into everything or if it's just
kind of like maybe it's like an iron
banner ish type activity that you get to
do from a week to week basis that gives
you another way to get acquired gear but
the gear looks amazing is like kind of
like Egyptian stuff i think the Hunter
has like mummy wraps and stuff like that
I think one of the things that I'm
really excited about about house of
wolves is just I think players are gonna
finally look very different from one
another previously the way Destiny's
work does everybody just equips the
highest
level raid here because that's what gets
you to whatever the highest levels at
that time and you know up until now like
everybody's wearing the same stuff so
now with the ability just with the like
they're adding a lot of new armor and
they're adding a lot of new weapons and
then on top of that now you can bring
your old stuff with you up to the max
level I just think it's going to be a
lot more diverse place to hang out yeah
I mean it's definitely gonna you're
gonna get some really cool looking guys
you're gonna get some clown looking guys
are going to get crazy with it but it
also helps min max right like I think
now you can go oh these gloves have my
aunt and discipline and it has you know
ammo reload and it or faster faster auto
rifle reload and more heavy Emma or
something like that so you can min max
your character even more than you were
before and you know it'll be nice to not
see everyone in glow who and like crotas
end gear maybe some people go back with
their vault gear where they mix match
who knows it'll be interesting to see so
based on what you saw in the stream
today are you going to be relapsing back
into destiny I am definitely I mean I
was already gonna play because not only
did i buy the season pass but now I'm
kind of at least juiced and amp to play
again there's a lot of these smaller
changes like the weapon upgrades and
whatnot that you know great I can find
lose my vex again and it's not kind of
gimped or I can use my fate bringer and
it's going to be badass because it's
going to be like 365 and my only I
wouldn't call it a concern it's like I
want to see what the endgame content
like I want to see if it lasts as long
as the raid does because the raid you
know it was hard for people right you
struggle through it so like you don't
always finish it the first week and then
you're trying to devise strategies we'll
have to see what the prison of elders
brings with it because there is going to
be riety week to week is going to differ
hopefully it's not just a horde mode
which kind of people are speculating
like that's what it is which is pretty
much what all of destiny is anyway I
mean a lot of this game let's be honest
is kind of horde mode yeah so I mean
it's it's how do they if it is going to
be some type of war mode how do they
twist it or shape it so it's different
like do they use baltinglass mechanics
where you do have to go through portals
and things like that where it kind of
changes up the pace of what you consider
horde mode and if they can do that and
it changes week to week maybe it has
like nightfall elements like there's arc
burn this week so they're more dangerous
are creatures or their heroic or things
like that like how are they going
shape that we don't know right like
that's my biggest question mark of what
is the longevity of this game because
we're excited to play again but the next
one might not come to like September or
something like that and that's a long
ways away hopefully it lasts for more
than a month or something